salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo salut mathieu
bonjour tout le monde donc mathieu on va
revenir sur une partie qui s'est jouée
hier en finale du quatrième grand prix
des speechs s féminin chess comme ces
faux suivant il faut suivre
elle qui a opposé du coup koné roues
avec les pièces blanches à kosteniuk et
juste avant de regarder la partie
kosteniuk à gagner cette finale hier
contre koné roues et elle affrontera
aujourd'hui lundi 20 juillet jour
internationale des échecs à 16h hanau
chez nina dans la grande finale des
finales des grands prix j'espère que
j'étais con si franchement c'était très
bien mais en plus en allemand ça va être
hyper interne parce qu'au vu des bas de
ceux - compétition les deux mérite
clairement leur place en finale elles
ont montré une régularité assez
hallucinante et non ça va être un beau
spectacle
moi je parie du coup moins la vidéo
reste donc on pourra me dire après je
pense que coucher nina va gagner
personnellement thiago silva écoute on
verra ce soir du coup une kosteniuk team
of china dans les annonces et je suis
pas pour me juger mais pour moi les
meilleurs
oui mon cher pour la poster et bien
maintenant on sait que l'on sait sur qui
on appareil est entre guillemets donc on
verra qui a réservé une petite bière
choisissez votre team les gars et donc
mathieu tu voulais revenir toi sur une
partie qui s'est jouée dans la finale
d'hier avec un pic à les blancs et qui
commence par la cavalière 3-1 pis pour
revenir un peu c'est une super joueuse
une cave arrêtés à calais pour nos
enceintes etc
mais par contre qu'il peu habitué à
internet je pense à lui a joué des tours
comme un oui fans d'ailleurs oui mais
super niveau et là on l a montré une
idée pas mal ce cas c'est marrant ça on
en a parlé dans les lives les jours
précédents moi j'ai de sarah sarah
sadate et en fait c'est une idée que
j'avais pensé pour ça raconte castagnou
donc ça vaut le simple fait rire quand
fait qu'elle est réussie elle ajouté
elle avait rappelé elle s'est rappelée
ouais mais je pense qu'elle lâche je
marque ok je l'avais dit joe des cats et
4 mai jeudi pour une partie qui est r3c
4 c'est pas bête avec une idée
exactement de la partie donc bien
veiller à 3 4 6 et 4 b6 dancoisne
indienne seynoise indienne en fait y'a
pas le pion en d4 donc c'est un homme de
coin assez souple pour les blancs parce
qu'on évite toutes les lignes avec
fougue et quatre échecs tu peux ça tu
peux le voir un peu après donc à temps
en 2006 roche est en fait si y'a pas fou
b 4 mai par exemple le des fautes star
de cou séquelles importantes peuvent jeu
ses 5es jeux de type hérisson mais après
je sais pas un si gros défaut il ya ces
joueurs pour les blancs mais ça aussi
toi tu avais identifié kosteniuk à la
joue et je sais que j'avais donc du fou
maintenant on joue des cas et ça nous
permet d'avoir évité des lignes avec les
donc petit rock est ici b3 donc tournoi
double chantier thau hb 3 c'est un cours
à et donc du coup moins mon idée que
j'avais mon tracera s'était pas deux des
quatre c'était de b3 d'abord et 30 la b3
ouais rock tomber deux des cinq n'est
pas le seul coup mais quel con principal
puis on prend cavaliers prend des quatre
et ça va être exactement la position de
la partie
zack est assez drôle d'accord donc à la
fée fuglseth des quatre crocs c'est rare
b3 normalement les gens jouent kayes et
3 les noirs font cavalier 4 tout autour
de la case eu quatre danses couverture
dans l'ouest indienne et on va voir ça à
son rôle n'a pas formellement le 2b 3
ans a fait don jeudi kbc 3 qui avait
lieu car et c'est là que ça joue pour la
case au carré des 3l l enjeu j'aurais de
fruits du pion avec les noirs parce que
j'aime bien les pions pendant mais un
autre débat j'allais dire que là du coup
si tu reprends du pion le
puis en d4 il le pion b3 avec le pion
des cats c'est un peu bizarre puisque
fou b2c pas trop une idée et un ouais
mais regarder non pas en quoi ce qu'ils
font passer ça aussi parce que s'ils
font ça et maintenant je peux prendre
mon four b2 il a donné vos dispose d'un
gag et c'est comme tout il ya du bon il
ya du cours du riz en enfer enfin en
fait tu lui dis mon fou en b2 il est mal
mais si tu fais pas assez cinq tons
chauds en b sat il est mal aussi longue
et les axonais tu acceptes une mauvaise
pièce parce que la pièce adverse et
mauvaise aussi donc apprend du cavalier
fouet deux une oxymore c'est quand je
m'étais préparée contre facebook quand
j'avais préparé comme quoi si duke
j'avais regardé surtout cavaliers ainsi
c'est le poste qui est 17 tu peux le
mettre ce que je pensais que c'était le
meilleur coût et elle l'avait joué en
2014 contre kramnik et elle avait battu
chronique dans un tournoi de beach à
moscou sais pas si tu te rappelles oui
ça je le rappelle qu est ce que j étais
mais parce que moi j'avais regardé 2,3
et la partie tu peux regarder s'était
cassé trois avec l'idée encore une fois
de contrôler la case de 4 c 5 et la
chronique avait jeu technique la finale
et d'ailleurs il avait été mieux mais
après il s'était fait retourner il avait
gaffé quatre ans c'est 5 c'était une
sphère des finiens un peu il ya un petit
avantage après cavaliers de simples mais
c'est typique des avantages de catalent
cd pas grand chose mais ça peut être un
peu chiant à jouer à cause de la casse
et 6 1 des finales passe donc dans la
partie elle a joué le coup le bouton
joue pourtant moins très bien joué parce
que si tu veux 4 tout de suite après
cavaliers abscisse en fait le pion
l'attaqué deux fois tu peux pas le
protéger et pendant je eu 5 serait une
seule petite erreur stratégique parce
qu'après caïds et 5
l'énorme enjeu c5 et le fou sera tout
dans tous les cas enfermé dans le pire
des cas tokyo ça c'est que maintenant
comparativement à tout à l'heure quand
on va te faire c'est ça je fais un coup
lambda quand on va verser 5 et qui va
échanger en fait si le plomb ayant eu
deux tons fauves et deux hybrides avec
cinq temps fou il reste bête et du coup
là les noirs ils ont une pièce qui vous
en plus entre eux il a case d3 pan-pot
très faible 1 5 x 6 x est une idée une
et trois d'accord et longues dents dans
la partie
j'ajouterai bien joué tour l'a donc
prépare en fait c'est la prophylaxie
sais tu veux jouer le 4 mai table tu en
as besoin de le défendre deux fois oui
claude tchou ces cinq normales
lecavalier a aussi ses mains la
différence et quick a attaqué deux fois
mais comme tu es défendu déjà une fois
tu peux d
parker est en fait le tempo est très
beau donc là les noirs on y perd
logiquement je comprends qu'ils aient
34,5 et donc du coup ça clp sont que
j'avais moi dans les zones très lisse et
là il ya un coût très important à
trouver qui est pas si simple
vous pouvez chercher si vous voulez
c'est d'un me 2 alors pourquoi ces
bassins parce qu'il ya une pièce en
prison des quatre oui donc tu donnes tu
donnes le cavalier des 4 mai sur dame
prend des quatre on voit que la dame est
dans le viseur du fouet la mathieu il ya
une grosse découverte
ouais quel dessein donc c'est pas la
partie à la paperie en déniant à la
paperie dams et 5.6 et la foux prend le
5e c'est le plus précieux mois jabra
gens à penser dans l'autre sens au début
on line et de la part de fou mais on
mais en fait ça c'est plus malin parce
que tu fais dans le c4 et après tu veux
joseph 4,5 ou kaïs et 6 puis f4 sein et
il n'y a pas tord c'est vite pour
contester la colonne oui c'est dingue
c'est pour jouer la finale
c'est un peu bizarre parce que quand tu
dis tu as pensé à cet ordre là juste
pour expliquer donc là on garde un
cavalier e set qui paraît mal placé mais
bon c'est prépare dit donc on sait qu'on
va réussir à faire f 4 c1 trois cette
année mais juste pour dire l'autre lors
de coups le plus logique le plus mince
fait heurter par cette dame 37 faut
prendre 5 parce que tu gardes un super
fou sans il habite à l'actuel tour s'est
vite il ya tour c'est 8
on est un peu mieux à côté de fou mais
ça reste quand même solide pour les
noirs mais ça c'est une différence
concrète gérard cas où tu demanderas un
être humain il va toujours te jouer fou
prend 1,5
il va assurer qu'il prend le stade d'un
projet c'est tout prendre 5 mais juste
sites analysés tu vas voir concrètement
que c'est plus fort ce à quoi vous allez
bon si tu me dis tempo tu fais quoi je
fais quelques points 16 mai si tu me
fait réfléchir
je peux trouver l'autre mais oui oui je
sais pas c'est pas naturel on est
d'accord donc sur une note de bien jouer
logique car deux idées en attaque deux
fois le pdk t ça peut nous donner la
case au sol pour la dame si oui ou non
mais hélas trop d un très bien joué mais
elle ajoute j'ai regardé les pendules ou
donc la lumière fou c'était 2007
mais les blancs sont un peu mieux avec
cavaliers à 4 car il aime vesle way
force vous prendrez cat et lambil et de
coûts ont été sauvées ouest et ceux-là
prix du fou mais il ya une partie par
cosmos où il a pris de la tour et je
pensais un peu
donc là jamais être solide mais on a les
deux fous donc on prétend un petit
avantage surtout rodez 1 elle a pris en
d4 elle n'a pas joué dams est surtout en
blitz est en nous oui car elle et b5
donc maintenant le fou est cloué il a
attaqué trois fois donc on va pas
pouvoir le défendre
mais ce qu'elle avait vu c'était fou
prend un f2 et chaque échec important
que ce soit un échec dans me prend d'un
bébé tu défends lecavalier st l asie bon
il ya un peu la tête mais j'ai un clou
de plus ça me paraît pas la fin des
moûts diagral il ya deux façons d'être
mieux pour les blancs et les deux sont
une nouveauté d'ailleurs elle a joué un
très bon call ashoka et des six
l'idée c'est qu'on attaque le foot 17 on
attaque le camaïeu de cinq et on défend
le cul 1,4 donc c'est un oui on en est
on à un cavalier fondamentalement très
bien placés puisqu'ils la vie touche un
peu afp est aussi dans certaines
variantes il est vraiment fantastique ce
qu'a laissé une plaie à morgane il y
avait un grand maître qui avait tour à
ses seins et c'est justement près 6 x 3
donne aussi un avantage d'après leur dit
alexis des fous des six mais souvent les
les
les noirs peuvent essayer de donner une
qualité par cavaliers au g4 2005 quelque
chose comme ça mais objectivement tu
sais qu'on craigne accueille des six
intermedia c'est quand même mieux pour
les mais bon ok l'enquêté elle a fait
franchement je trouve ça même plus fort
et plus logique est donc là elle a joué
cavalier e 17 qui est une faute déjà
décisive décisive
il fallait jouer l'autre mais allez
jouer ça ouais mais on va pas regarder
qu'on le montrera après parce que c'est
intéressant de voir pourquoi qu'il y
avait eu des sept pères et là j'ai
regardé l ai réfléchi une minute trente
elle est passée de 3 minutes 30 à 2
minutes et elle a trouvé le bon coup
elle a trouvé le coup qui gagne mais
super cool et g4g moi je regardais en
live et j'avais l'évaluation de l'ordi
et je me disais que ce coût était
quasiment introuvable parce que tu as
beaucoup d'attaqués tu sais pas de temps
et drogué qui prend b 7 5
j'ai envie de jouer torah c'est un temps
envie de jouer tour des deux temps vijay
d'un f4 tu as plein de coups qui sont
tentants et g4 évidemment c'est tentant
aussi parce que tu dis sur qui à
l'étranger catch faire d'alger 3 monts
d'or c'est la partie et je vais massacré
g7 mais il faut quand même comprendre
que j'ai 5 etc
c'est une grosse menace en fait la
menace aussi juste dame g3 et g5 et en
fait on va désorganiser compte
demant le le camp adverse parce que
cavale de huit sadr a toujours une pièce
cahier premier set
oui le puits un cat est toujours défendu
et non mais c'est juste ça gagne tapas
tour des huit passes kg cinq essais pour
soigner des gens et de la gaze afsset
tout à l'heure à j-6 on fait juste h4h
qu'a t on côté la jeune dame g3 mais
c'est les deux marches donnant du coup
on regarde le bon coup cavalli on a dit
qu'il fait les jeux call ya le 17 et 17
mais là c'est assez drôle en fait il ya
g4 m alors c'est un peu c'est moins fort
parce qu'on peut le h6 dame g3 hong kong
menaçe 5 m6 et la tour c'est un pas
domination totale tour dès 8 h 4 est la
potion pour moi tient pas c'est terrible
parce que tu as ta les tours bien placé
talent car ayant des six ans ferme
toutes allées noires qui ont des pièces
complètement dans le 5e le prochain coup
et tu vas faire g5 et tu vas voir la
synergie foulée deux dames g3 qui va
taper sur sur g7
c'est une jolie et donc du coup c'est
non sujet 4 soit le couple est en fait
de cahiers des six on sait très bien je
donc elle a joué pour revenir
particulier 17 g4 elle allait prendre
angers 4 maintenant dame j'ai trois
attaques le cavalier sur cavaliers df 6
6 a bêtement h3 l'asie et sur cagliari
sur le clouage donc sur g4 qui avait
plongé quatre dames g3 elle a joué
cavalier jf si ça les revenus et
maintenant je vais lui mettre la main
minutes mignonnette mais non leurs
causes
si vous souhaitez cherchez pas très dur
à ce niveau là pour pour une pige en
août et prend des risques elle a vu
quand elle a jugé que tu apprends 17
tours prend 17 maintenant on peut pas
prendre du cavalier meschia mat
angers7 du coup on est obligé de prendre
de la dame maintenant fou prend f6
menace m'attend g7 g6 et là tous les
coups gagnants
il suffit juste de ramener la dame en
uf6 donc cela me 3 d'un f4 amont et même
damage 4 mai bondam g5
c'est le plus logique on menace d'un
match 6 dames g7 et à kosteniuk a
abandonné ben ouais super party connu je
pense et une bonne prépa est par contre
une minute trente pour trouver g4 il
fallait le trouver parce que c'est un
super coup et après bon c'est pas
logique on doit jouer sur les cases
noires
mais dynamique on a un peu moins mais
mes copines mois les joueuses qui m'ont
vraiment impressionné dans le fond de
jeu c'était oui fans à koné roues et a
joué john les trois m'ont paru vraiment
stratégiquement plus jouer je n'ai pas
m'a pas impressionné mais par contre ok
pour moi les deux autres sont les deux
meilleurs et jouer le jeu d'un oeil et
le double du monde mais elle est aussi
triki moi j'avais été impressionné par
son match contre gouina où elle a
simplement perdu parce qu'à un moment
donné à la plus de connexion internet et
elle passe elle mène 3-0 et elle perd
une partie des gagnants ce qu'elle est
déconnecté elle passa à 3 puis elle perd
une autre partie qui n'est pas claire
sur des connexions ça passe à 3 2 donc
au lieu de 4 0 avec possibilité de 5,0
ça passe à 3 2 après en bullet en plus
avaient plus de connexion mais à la
manière dont elle avait battu dont elle
dominait avec laquelle elle dominait
gouina ça m'avait vraiment impressionné
c'était très solide très stratégique
très embêté bounine assez salée super
forte et imaginative très tactique mais
enfin moi je la connais depuis longtemps
c'est pas à compréhension stratégique
c'est pas son point fort non mais tu
vois il avait battu un peu à leur bar
contre des mecs comme neige médecine
offre tu vois ce genre de d'opposition
style bon mathieu sur ce on se retrouve
à 16 heures pour les parties et bah tout
à l'heure